[la musique]
chers citoyens de Russie
Chers amis
prend fin
2021 va bientôt changer d'heure
nous du passé au futur
oui ça arrive tous les jours pendant une minute et
seconde mais ce passage continu du temps
nous entendons clairement quand nous nous rencontrons
nous attendons la nouvelle année comme une vie importante
frontière nous sommes tous unis maintenant par l'espoir
pour les bons changements à venir, mais nous
nous comprenons qu'ils ne peuvent pas être arrachés
distinct des événements de l'année à venir, nous
faire face à d'énormes défis, mais
appris à vivre dans des conditions aussi difficiles
incapable de résoudre des problèmes complexes
faire avec notre solidarité
ensemble continué à combattre le dangereux
épidémie qui a balayé tous les continents
et jusqu'à ce qu'ils se retirent
maladie insidieuse a fait des dizaines de milliers de victimes
des vies
Je tiens à exprimer mon soutien sincère
à tous ceux qui ont perdu des êtres chers
chers amis, le plus important est que tout
nous avons surmonté les difficultés de l'année écoulée
ensemble ont défendu ceux qui étaient dans
situation difficile d'abord.
soutenir les personnes âgées et
familles où les enfants grandissent l'avenir de la russie
nous avons fermement et constamment défendu
nos intérêts nationaux
la sécurité du pays et des citoyens en peu de temps
le moment a rétabli l'économie et à bien des égards
les postes vont maintenant être mis en place
objectifs stratégiques de développement
bien sûr, il y a encore beaucoup de problèmes non résolus
beaucoup mais cette année nous avons passé dignement
le principal mérite ici appartient à
vous citoyens de Russie est le résultat
vos chers amis travaillent dur
chacun à sa place cherchait
remplir son devoir de faire non seulement cela
ce qui est en son pouvoir mais aussi beaucoup plus pour aider
ceux qui ont un cœur particulièrement difficile
merci à tous en ce moment difficile
car c'est maintenant une attitude très importante pour
l'aspiration à la création est obligatoire
réaliser vos projets personnels et apporter
avantage pour la société et le pays d'origine et
célébrant la nouvelle année, nous espérons qu'il
ouvrira de nouvelles possibilités
on compte sur la chance, bien sûr, mais c'est tout
nous comprenons que la réalisation du plan
Tout d'abord, cela dépend de nous
ce que nous priorisons
remplir le quotidien
résolument actif se mettre au travail et
réaliser concrètement visible
résultats
d'entre eux sera la mise en œuvre
notre plan national leur principal
l'objectif d'améliorer le bien-être et la qualité
la vie des gens
la solution de ces tâches précisément fera de la Russie
encore plus fort et seulement ensemble nous
nous pouvons assurer un développement ultérieur et
prospérité de notre pays
chers amis le réveillon du nouvel an littéralement
rempli de bons sentiments et lumineux
les pensées
le désir de chacun de montrer son meilleur
qualité et dans une telle ouverture de générosité
l'essence et l'énergie de ce merveilleux
des vacances quand ça devient si important
parents chaleureux avec attention et soin
embrasser s'ils sont autour dire à tout le monde
proches comme ils vous sont chers
bonheur quand il y a amour enfants famille
les amis sont tous de grandes valeurs qui
déterminent largement le sens de la vie pour chacun
Humain
nous voulons tous dans l'année à venir
ils sont restés pour nous les mêmes fiables
soutien et maintenant nous nous empressons d'admettre
cher à nous les gens au plus profond de nous
sentiments pour dire ces mots sincères
amour et gratitude pour lesquels parfois
il n'y a pas assez de temps dans l'agitation quotidienne, mais
la vraie magie du Nouvel An là-dedans et
comprend
qui ouvre nos cœurs à la sensibilité et
confiance en la noblesse et la miséricorde, et où
si vous n'étiez pas en cercle à ce moment
famille et amis sur les places des proches
partout les villes sonnent le plus chaud
souhaits avec
Je suis heureux de les rejoindre et je veux
féliciter tout le monde pour la nouvelle année
qui exécute maintenant
devoir professionnel et militaire
sauve et soigne les malades
sur un poste de combat pour fournir
la loi et l'ordre n'est pas interrompu le travail sur
autoroutes sur plusieurs
services de production et de maintien de la vie
des centaines de milliers de nos
citoyens
merci pour responsable important pour
pays et sociétés travail
faites glisser des amis en quelques secondes
la nouvelle année viendra et dans de nombreuses familles de
y compris nos compatriotes pour
en dehors de la Russie sonnera traditionnel
bonne année avec de nouveaux bonheurs ces
des mots simples que nous prononçons avec
sentiment parce qu'ils sont transmis de
sincèrement génération après génération
toutes nos félicitations
le souhait principal de tous bien sûr
bonne santé et j'en suis sure
la réussite dans le travail et les études sera appliquée dans
créativité et activité préférée, que ce soit chez tout le monde
la maison aura autant de différents
événements, laissez les nouveaux apparaître plus souvent
familles les enfants naissent laissez les grandir
sain
location intelligente honnête et gratuite
l'amour sera dans chaque coeur et
nous inspire tous à atteindre
objectifs et la génération des plus
de grands sommets pour le bien de leurs proches et pour le bien de
notre seule grande patrie avec
bonne année chers amis
2020 deuxième année
[la musique]
mais